let's talk about anti-semitism i've
talked about right-wing and left-wing
anti-semitism before and many of us on
the left are quick to admit that
anti-semitism on the right is a major
problem
and it is a major problem and i've
talked about it before right right-wing
anti-semitism from
white nationalists the patriot and
militia type movements
many sources of right-wing anti-semitism
but we're also seeing left-wing
anti-semitism and it's coming from
different places it's sometimes coming
on college campuses
it's sometimes from so-called
african-american
rights groups that we've covered in the
past anti-semitic statements and
and uh uh um uh i guess statements is
what i what i would really call it
proclamations of sorts
and the causes of left-wing
anti-semitism are different
than the causes on the right and this
isn't a comprehensive list
but left-wing anti-semitism sometimes
stems from
antipathy towards israeli foreign or
domestic policy
it can stem from the perception that
despite being one of the most persecuted
groups in human history jews are now
seen by some as a privileged group in
some countries
and sometimes as a group undeserving of
the so-called privilege
that they're perceived to have sometimes
it's related to straight-up conspiracy
theories of control
sometimes it's merely the feeling that
in order to be for palestinian rights
you have to be more vocally against jews
at large
there's many reasons that i haven't
mentioned and it's also combinations of
the reasons that i have
in any case college campuses are quickly
becoming an epicenter
of left-wing anti-semitism and there
have been some horrible incidents over
the last week or so
recently there was an event called the
chicago dyke march
on saturday it's an lgbt rights event
and three people
carrying jewish pride flags in other
words it's
it's a rainbow lgbtq flag
with the star of david in the middle
basically saying hey the jewish
community supports lgbtq rights
they were asked to leave the march
because they quote repeatedly expressed
support for zionism which is a by and
large
pretty meaningless phrase and one member
of the dyke march collective said that
those people carrying the rainbow flags
with the star of david in the middle
were total leaves because people to
leave because people were feeling
unsafe as a result of the flags adding
that the march was
an anti-zionist pro-palestinian march
according to the windy city times and
one of those people who was kicked out
of the march said
she was approached multiple times about
her flag this is laurel grower
who said they were telling me to leave
because my flag was a trigger
to people that they found offensive
a member of the dyke march collective
spoke to the chicagoist on sunday
and insisted oh no our organization
isn't anti-semitic
but we don't want to be associated with
anything that could be interpreted as
pro-israel
and the dyke march organizers
subsequently released a statement
explaining that the decision to remove
jewish marchers was quote made after
they
repeatedly expressed support for zionism
during conversations with dyke march
collective members
what was one of those expressions of
zionism
well laurel grower said that she
believes in a two-state solution
to the israeli-palestinian conflict and
apparently that was just
too much listen uh infighting
is a destructive force in social
movements and the lgbtq movement
as has been exposed by a number of good
investigative pieces
is having an issue with anti-semitic
elements and it's particularly
self-destructive
and disturbing to see groups fighting
for minority rights
often reject the support of jews in the
black community
which in some places is directly at odds
with jews for example
near where i used to live in brooklyn in
south williamsburg brooklyn in new york
city
there is pretty significant tension
between the hasidic and black
communities there
and it's extra upsetting to me to see
that giving the long
long very long history in the united
states of jews being there
fighting for minority rights lgbtq
rights
african-american rights mississippi
burning right many people don't know
this
mississippi burning the movie based on
the 1964 murders
of three civil rights workers during the
civil rights movement
two of the three people killed there
were jews and
historically jewish groups have been at
the forefront of fighting for lgbt
rights groups like the anti-defamation
league
this is so toxic and so destructive and
at the core whatever your feelings are
pat
movements that start this infighting end
up
mostly hurting themselves it really is
too bad that this is going on
on the left uh if you look at the other
side republicans have had a big issue
with racism ever since
lyndon johnson signed the south away
with the civil rights act and the voting
rights act sure
now of course that's not indicative of
every republican and it's small in
numbers but still very significant
sure and that's why i think um you know
conservatives do have a responsibility
to call
their fellow racist conservatives out on
that as do we and if
this continues to grow we'll have that
res that same responsibility when it
comes to anti-semitism on the left
couldn't agree more couldn't agree more
and this is just i mean
what are we gaining what what did the
lgbtq rights
pride movement gain by kicking someone
out
for having a flag that indicated the
jewish community supports lgbtq rights
and believed in a two-state solution to
the israeli-palestinian conflict explain
to me
how the march was better off okay